but have no money
Zynga's dance I'm gonna hear some of my
dress 1932 won't be long
if the rig
hey no joke garden some you're wrong pro
volleyball
along here drool over you and shut your
mouth you never been to school without
you something over all got broke we got
nothing but a carbon tax and all alone
just breaking our backs exactly please
carvings okay I
yes
it will do 11 this is some car white
house blues and the original White House
piece was written about the McKinley's
assassination in buff and buff money and
the Kennedy was very beloved president
so some of the next period morning this
there was a song right Bob and this song
White House boobs is nothing to do with
kindling but it's the same melody and
it's the same phrase but the worst that
were rewritten applied to cooler not
dying but leaving White House and
Roosevelt moving in so what's it
you
I want you gone you went all publishing
Oh
baby
down
Oh
we're getting there
four hours for your work and say
now he's dog
Oh
you
now he's gone
plans go
there's no getting there for me now he's
gone
see what you got
I'm
so we want to invite a little bit of
discussion we have these 20 songs about
stop any things you notice or think
about what kind of other surprises are
there things that are a little bit what
you might not have expected in the
lyrics what if you had a return the
theses texts if you found them in an
interview what are they telling you
about this helps me understand people's
political meetings
that's really cool I would answer that
too by saying that it also shows you how
impersonal local people felt with the
politics of the gun they were involved
in they were knowledgeable so they could
they could make up these lyrics and the
abbot's resonate with other people over
the course of time but a manifold
well it's this is this know you could
play a lot with this song in a time of
one percent to ninety-nine percent to
forty-seven percent and so on and
clearly there's something about the
leveling effect of hard times that
people noticed and that bowl song was
all that it made us all for not only
more human even more equal because we're
all in the same boat and that's what
each of those verses is about somebody
who once was privileged if one wants to
imagine you know and Romney going door
to door selling magazines I happen I was
thinking about the issue of fact vs vs
the narration and it doesn't really
matter when you hear the sound whether
it's fact or not and we've said about
Pete Seeger suddenly a memory came back
to me of being in the backseat of the
car with my sister you should sing when
we were on the trip and fight like crazy
about the wards and we always resolved
it by saying well it's a folk song over
here I was going to say that these songs
are about economic devastation but the
songs themselves restore the dignity of
being of the seer and and they're quite
cheerful musically yeah that's a greater
which that struck us too yeah are the
reason we were so drawn to the music
because it's really about a devastating
period of time in yet as soon as you say
about it
yeah it was did I wonder if it must have
made a difference to them to be able to
find this kind of an elevator and Sharon
and you tell people as I do that her to
amuse Great Depression and lexapro
versus I should rest of the music is not
like that even that the blue shoes from
the east coast or not these desperate
songs part of it is Baker said were so
bad that they had to find the lighter
side to it and the other is my opinions
of the resiliency Americans at that time
he was still team doing a lot of first
generation we still talked about the
promised land that this was God's people
get a lot of the one who came before the
panic the panic is on which is about a
lot of our things but there's a lot of
energy in that and there's the humor and
there's the way it ends up we've always
been struck with how many of these songs
field of prohibition we think about FDR
the reveal but they're coming out of the
20s and so one of the dominant realities
one of the things that's really powerful
about Roosevelt is that he got rid of
kovash and that matter and so that old
Panik is on song you're not real I was
not prepared as one you know let me
after another of people you know sort of
scrabbling by and that old last verses
about you know until we have cheap wine
you know like mine beer and gin the kind
of is still on so yeah
that in taxi driving X stock broker is
kind of presented in a pretty
sympathetic way that seems to stand in
kind of stark contrasts with the
attitude that would make a pretty boy
floyd in such an appealing
and then I realized that it was raped by
a sales manager at atendimento he
injected what was also a sense that
being a stockbroker is not you're not in
a centralized eternal member of an elite
that you could be brought down like
anybody else and then you're sitting
there driving a taxi kick and therefore
we can you can get with it and I think
those days you didn't have stock or
forsaking successfully million a year
ladies you know of our middle class
money please and very few people in
stock but everybody used to be in a
one-percent world it's really hard to
imagine those people from Lehman
Brothers has Iseman or try to without
understanding or sometimes well there
was there's a lenda that struck me
curious in Brooklyn
where that I think it's a second verse
for this city it's rich man's job to
make the rules in order to read our
bread left loose it's very interesting
observation at that is almost successful
the rich are in power and it is their
job to softest crime and the writer some
seem very content about ideas just that
they're not doing it and because I'm not
doing it that motion remove the donkey
what struck me about them than their
visit they're speaking in a collective
speaking for us is thinking for we and
the gilded ran things about the nation
and you know in oral history story has
said many of them are individual or more
localized or something like that with
that confidence and that they're singing
or speaking on behalf of the whole
community
yeah you can notice that in a lot of the
songs even in the follicle a night where
they have their mind flutter makes us
all very human that's a really different
sentiment than by now with people facing
hard times they don't there there's a
lot more blaming going on and a lot more
polarization a division yeah goddamn
Robert container we used to be a writer
for the nation wrote a book on the 1930s
looking back five decades anyways with
the group at times yeah underscore the
point for combat is and you'll see this
in some of the other ones coming up is
that the the position in these songs is
sometimes really simple and not
something that falls into a depth in
about it's the rich man's job to make
some rules and I elites are fine if they
actually did it and we're looking out
for the rest of us like you know we're
going to have no less of leaves let's
have real bleach please no so that
doesn't fit the easy categories of 1%
you're going to my person and I think
you'll find some of the others we do
with really surprising complexity and it
sort of forces you to think about things
more than rather than just find
something that you can attach to a
particular pre-existing position so
we're going to do a couple now get move
it along and focus a little bit on
Roosevelt and the power that he had and
it's another level of the folk music
it's not just about politics but about a
particular you know emotional connection
to do our deal and will be some things
here I think the first one will do
without the slides and then
this song is written by a guy named Bill
croxleys or Charleston West Virginia and
he tell us the story is prescribed for
rosemary from a different very different
even
well soldier
me
you
you're fired jump so he won't be
unpacking
while I was digging around in the live
water inside the rooster for me go
through fatty working I'll snap your old
puppy and say
Oh
you
they add me on the race
the present o.o to Ranger delete my
friend I'll snapped in old
see
we're gonna miss me now that I'm get
along but when the angels find me I'll
be sleeping in 100
me
sextoon about an event allegedly
happened although a lot of booze
historian verified it was a man named
Sylvester Harris Mississippi the old
farm he was about to lose his farm and
his meal which was his version of
attractor and very distressed in this
one salsa blossom basic fence about that
time people actually didn't pick up the
telephone call the White House and some
talk to present they never talk to the
president but he got a whole team people
who answer the moment like right down
people's individual problems and so the
story goes that Harris cause the White
House and he gets em but the anxiety
caused that the next night and Roosevelt
had been brought into this library and
he was waiting for miss Celie angeles
assistant to come in and choose an
answer the phone and he was just going
to sit there and she was late so the
phone rang and he picked it up and it
was Sylvester and Sylvester said
this tells majorities in losses Harmon
responses Sylvester don't worry you will
hear from me and stories he contacted
refinance administration contacted the
bank and they saved silvestri sperm the
next Thanksgiving and every Thanksgiving
until Roosevelt died Warm Springs
Georgia where goes about his
Thanksgiving subgiant turkey and one of
the Roosevelts mates said the first time
first turkey the ride she brought in the
president's hands with Cartman's just
signed Sylvester she was about to
explain typical Sylvester keys car keys
Sylvester Harris at one around these
tremors so this song was performed by
Memphis many wonderful great great blues
singers of all time we don't think she
wrote we don't know who wrote in all
likelihood best guesses a guy in kc bill
well who she was living with at the time
whose guitar player and wrote some WP
ourselves and touch recorded Sylvester
sided
he said the president
so that's when I across the field
looking at brand mom he cry alone about
this my own tell us when I across his
feet look into
Oh
if I'm at the president he got all the
while he my home I'll die he's all
about the president and he got all if I
lose my
yes
you
call the president on the telephone I
want to talk to you about to lose my
only call the president
I want talk to you about
first time they call him somebody else
wanna talk to that man I wanna sleep
with mr. president roosevelt first time
you called someone else
don't want to talk to my man I want to
speak mr. Roosevelt he said Sylvester
you can take your eat just take that
people jackass go back out in your field
he sets it was you can take your email
just hang at me go check
sweet over here
in Marseilles from day
Oh
all the penis
never
Oh
yes
good sleepy
people Oh No
Wow
Oh
No
the greater peace of Mary
ha
Oh
right
you
my awesome cook
oh I was said because that is one of my
favorite footage it was taken by your
feeling and she captioned all of her
photos sometimes with several lines but
this one she just kept she captioned it
a very who do you think it was position
about photographers well he was one of
the photographers that sometimes would
make suggestions to get the photo that
you either but I've never heard of her
actually physically manipulate
a picture like that I don't think that
she did I don't know it and there's
nothing that ever said that she did I
always assumed that she came upon it
that way and remind you soon but I this
is a question
secondly
and judging from the lyrics it seems
kind of like a response to an early
setback of New Deal legislation and I
was wondering if there was any optimism
about the legislation that replaced the
NRA was that was that the NRI day and
where was that
labor relations a lot of it if they
Wagner after national labor relations
that was passive in six months repeal
and that was started by Wagner from New
York and that really embraced all the
labor aspects of culture barman child
and that was probably notice this had
worked his way through the course and
thank everyone in roseland
administration except Frank so it was a
good shot so that was the Wagner Act was
the attempt to really manipulate the
economy and pricing and wages I don't
think there was another specific piece
of new legislation to try
but the interesting thing about the song
I mean you know we obviously deal today
with the question of what do you do if
there's a Supreme Court that takes on
the role of blocking a lot of
initiatives and that was certainly their
situation and roosevelt made the choice
as many of you know to try to
reconstruct the Supreme Court which was
a disastrous miscalculation it was seen
as to me that was the perfecting plan to
try to sort of get more people that he
could appoint in the court because he
wasn't going to be points and what the
song talks about is the popular response
which was the NRA been all about large
scale industry and labor rights and the
major organizing drives of the CIO with
the response to the labor movement to
this basically take my dad's things up
to us in the streets and organizing to
do what the government is only so much
the government can do it now the Supreme
Court is blocking them and that's not
likely to change quickly enough and so
in that song itself it's sort of a
surprising part of the lyric that
basically shows the shift now we have
the UMWA the Mine Workers Union which is
one of the major focuses of the NRA and
think how much you've got a 1932 England
how much you know we haven't what's the
line we order now the UMW of a and so
that's really traces that shift and
again this to me is an example of where
in this case the folk music is making a
very profound political point that most
of the textbooks which talk only about
the court packing plan as if the Supreme
Court politics are limited to the
Washington Beltway and Roosevelt's
response and then they deal with the cio
drives later and the song is showing a
direct connection of one has a response
to the other which is a pretty profound
to starboard side
okay probably the retrospective moment
conservatism is the most popular piece
of internal legislation creating
Civilian Conservation Corps which those
people think was a pretty good thing in
a very short period of time let's look
for several hundred thousand ccc in this
format to be conservation primarily but
also come money into the economy and to
service as a job training program for
young men and they to the age of 17 and
20 prayer you could join the nra for
six-month terms the ccc and you were
paying thirty dollars a month 25 we hope
your family and private identity and
they lived in military-style barracks
that was set up by retired military
people and so it was like entering the
army but you did conservation work in
different tech support and remember in
1933 many very few people trapped and so
for most of these young men they never
been away from home before so they sense
the idea that these kids are not going
to be happy hard work and they're going
to get homesick so they transferred so
if you lived in New York City and you
join the nra chances at ease event of a
CCC
he'd end up in carlsbad new mexico for
someone so it was too far to he can come
home so there were a lot of homesick
people so this song is unlike some of
the other songs that glorify the mythity
legislation this is a very low speed on
man the keys of the captain Texas heard
someone second who said he learned it
from his boyfriend in camp offense but
doesn't make CCC we attempt to just kiss
me back your mind but i'll talk about
these two is a bracket if the nra songs
are really like folk music pushing a
good history text into complex areas
these two are most surprising they're
not what you think the history text
would be focused on at all and we might
talk about what you find
we won't have to when I
when her only hero when he won't be
lonesome a mall
wait you have
the way
I
Oh
me
all the drugs has little go bankrupt on
that thing because cosmetics they will
put away on a shelf and your grandma
when her holding tension
Oh
if you want almost and you're down to
Washington and all the attention man
will be around if you want
then you're done for
and our second band will be air
we're about for the wonderful surprises
does anyone know who the old-age pension
man that they're referring to it's a man
called Charles Thompson he was a doctor
and he came up with a plan before Social
Security was introduced he came up with
the plan for everybody to pitch in the
dime and he was going to start a fund
that would send pensions to it was
called the Thompsons land there were
talking clubs all over the United States
people in towns got together and started
these clubs and Corel subscribers and
well there was there's a huge movement
for some sort of retirement plan in fact
that guy Leo Danville patio din that was
how he was elected governor of taxes he
because he didn't do it but he promised
everybody else this retirement plan and
rose about really wasn't ready for it he
penned trying to delay the Townsend
became so popular channels his plan was
based on the sales tax and it was
totally unfeasible it was not possible
way that we raced up like
retirement but it became popular in
these Townsend clubs impending illusion
there were 5,000 of them and you paid a
dime every month and the diamond to
Washington for lobby and so there's the
line of the song the sender times to
Washington the gimmick of the plan which
is a really interesting an economic
insight was that people old age people
would get these pensions with one
condition that they had to spend it with
in germany vs so the idea was that this
money would then be recycled through the
economy that just went into the mattress
it wasn't really helping prime the pump
of recovery so they were thinking hard
about how do you get an economy that's
installed into motion so it was a kind
of incentive or stimulus plan to link in
this sense that funding of what will
become social security to get that money
into circulation usually a really forced
the social security legislation because
it was becoming so popular this whole
notion in it you know the sales tax
thing didn't work there's no way it
wasn't economist in this country it's
that could vouch for the numbers so
really forced roosevelt and congress to
pass
legislation but it's not thinking that
there was pictures of them you might
have seen a white here but aside from
all the politics what else you've read
in that song as a way in which this folk
music is sort of changing your
expectations not quite a debate about
social security so both of those the CCC
blues is constant all of them this is
you know not rah rah for a government
program in Lewis there's a lot of the
Indians and people in the camps that the
experience was very different than
that's what the folk music in this case
is about for the powerful records we in
fact we found a few other CCC songs and
most of them are pretty santaquin area
yes in the photographs for the most part
they look like they did the network
would have been the way music camp in
there too until a place
and then the last two cents are
essentially about the Dust Bowl and
about migration and migratory workers
and a lot of the stuff that feeds into
that part of the particularly the FSA
work in the Michael show so the first
group is three songs essentially about
migration and homesickness at
and we have to be satisfied with
the face ring
I
forget my friend
Oh
I
in temair and action because of me
Oh
I join
you
we're crazy
Oh
love you
go
I declare we love it we're crazy
oh you know
your
yeah we hear lots of lots of examples of
a folk song that becomes very popular
estoppel just did we learned from a tape
done in migrant camps Simon this very
kind of hosting well the song was
written by Bob Wills who was a swing
musician from Oklahoma but quite a lot
of texas and was the movie 19 for you
only text river called go back to
Oklahoma and South Dakota Columbus
actually a swing sunny and we have today
bill quick from the movie of them
singing the song so you can see where
this person we heard we learned it up
must have seen this in the movies or her
recording which was a very top and then
turned it into what we thought was very
sad well you know like this
Oh
that's what you think wait to get the
Pico up about the there's a
sense you know when I'm a serious level
that in a lot of treatments of focus
that the photon imagine is in this sort
of timeless essential folk world you
know not really conscious actors in
their real society and as you've earned
a lot of these songs they're really
quite engaged and so there's no reason
why people I mean I phone interviews
with old Fiddler's great to learn that
song thinking it was going to be to
somebody's great rank are miscible offer
the radio come to Chicago so they are
really in their world and processing
things and in this case taking a popular
movie and turning it into a very
different song when Tom founded in New
York talk about folk music as auto
industry but some of this is folk music
in oral history and sort of talking to
each other so you have just a couple of
things that are drawn from a lot of the
interviews that are in the same library
of congress recordings that were Tom
found below the songs and so you get
things like this and I want you to be
helpful to really hear some of these
voices and you can think about the
connections to the songs of your throat
I'll just play a couple of business as
the indexing program that we use in a
lot of the work that we've done
very helpful for this reason I could we
progress words to me that support my
family being a lot six kids and I'm not
to do that with timber worth it when you
color it wouldn't currently have it
solely you'll be done on reported but if
you sold it okay and I used to set that
hotel may add a cross the street we're
takin was lined up down the streets with
buttons in his hand one hit ruckus super
coming but huge black clouds look like
to poke around the train station I got
four pump 1930s control little rain that
was my offseason all afraid me funny and
ridiculous and it was just so dark in
there we couldn't see more than just had
evil annoyed with and we talked mutters
and
oh I'm builders oh my gams budget does
anything face boy just come here come
here is the right time he comes another
time he jumped across and it sure does
this time and i own the early and i made
forth in oklahoma city oklahoma and
started california and that their fate
of oklahoma city were getting door hi
how they don't want it will hold this
lifting philippine jacket sky about a
party next morning and in the cotati
free walked off without any breakfast
and left alone baby sleep and then i'll
get at take cydia walk down 60 highway I
have a good reason for leaving so I hate
for Pacific bay then I've seen the Texas
and Mexico bottomless Lake and ours only
seem different
night one night I heard you love child
fell into the pit for one I wanted it
the poor little creatures didn't have
home baby back my best thing that I've
raised my heart he said boy when hear
him go back said give him down as your
heart that city and I do a little rustic
in shape I started this morning one bed
my bed lying out on the ground and
covered up my homies ages and smokes
sugar and lay down and I take these in
Californy from 26 hours a day five Rick
you can ride along wide open I thought
ever such a typo oh this is not an
example of what some of the field
recording sound like them are very
continuous with the oral histories and
from the other songs I'm California
model that belt fire pit fell pony I am
ft away I no longer in extra flavor
although it was like giving your fellow
I never growing we know body was there
from harbour castle my mother was
sleeping in the gay little hound for
things and her love of the things are
like them I thought ever thought I would
not go no other way fan you may see cold
but the market was like a little bell
rings that I hate it turns out if
there's a lot of surprising connections
between the oral histories and the
localism so this is sort of a how can
you pick to folk music seriously so want
you to listen to a couple of things that
we were alert to because we knew the
words of some of the songs then I'll
play the song so these are some unusual
turns of phrase and a lot of your
working on the street off and pay
attention to how people say things so we
don't presume and an eyes-only then in
standardizing good
okay that word landed finding nobody
songs I felt that I land in California I
landed well they're not flying so you
might think about that we can talk about
what where that term comes from it what
what it evokes and as opposed to saying
we arrived in California but we land in
a California or Arizona and another
terrible fissionable among the grapes of
wrath but I find that if we live right
someway somehow we'll find the happy
landings sooner or later so that's um
again landing and another phrase we
heard is this woman in the cold open
california in 38 and painful there's
some others came quite a flood it came a
flood and here is a quote from missoni
will do called sunny Cal by mending jack
ryan and you listen yogi or both of
those phrases that we pointed out
we just started working up these but I
think you're going to find we're going
to find lots of places where as we get
deeper into these interviewing errors
there's lots of evidence of a kind of
continuity of sensibility between the
way people talk and the way the songs
are written at once as they say and
cultural studies what's inscribed in
these songs through the language choice
of the people making sleep
sorry
you
but I
Oh
we know
I'm
Oh
it wasn't